all right thanks again to ryan pace
great to talk to him i know matt maggie
was recently on lunch talk live with
mike tarico it's good to see the bears
get a little more involved you know
there was a period of time where they
shied away from the national engagement
and uh look i i think it makes sense and
obviously i've got a bias in all this
but it makes sense for as many teams as
possible to be willing to do interviews
and make people available because we are
the conduit between the fans
and the teams and we try to ask the
questions that fans would ask we try to
get the information that fans would be
interested in and we try to enhance the
overall experience of following the nfl
by getting these folks to talk and
getting them in a setting other than a
press press conference is tough because
a press conference is just like a
question on this and the question on
that question on that without any real
flow or follow-up or conversation and i
don't think you see
the real person the way that you do in a
more extended interview so we appreciate
ryan pace for giving him given us some
of his time today and we hope to be
talking to him and coach negi in the
future all right some of your questions
here
pft pm posse as usual at the top of the
stack and i'm going to do this i was
going to try to do it on my laptop but i
think it's easier to just work off my
cell phone here philadelphia's brandon
graham said trash talk can replace fan
noise but how will nfl
officials keep us from hearing the
extremely vulgar words without constant
bleeps ruining it ruining it or a delay
that could impact
gambling the pftp and policy would love
to hear it unbleeped but knows nfl
equals no fun league well i'll tell you
what you know what
i kind of i kind of like the espn espn2
option that we saw for the last dance
would it be possible that for cable
broadcast now it's not going to be
possible for fcc regulated three-letter
network over-the-air fcc broadcast but
for cable games
you could do two fees you could do the
adult feed the life is rated r feed with
all of the profanity i don't know if the
nfl is going to go all in for that but
we see it every year on hard knocks we
see it on amazon's all or nothing it's
up on this and f-bomb that they embraced
it there so maybe maybe
that's where we're headed maybe the last
dance is going to innovate sports
coverage to multiple feats
if we're going to be hearing what these
guys are saying
and now it's not going to be easy to
believe that's for sure and that's the
challenge for the fcc regulated version
of these broadcasts what do you do if
you're picking up all this language
because look even though
guys will be more aware of what they say
if they know that that the things
they're saying in the trenches on the
field on the sidelines wherever can
potentially be heard by the home
audience once the game gets started
you're going to forget about it you're
going to get numb to it you're going to
just go about your business once your
adrenaline gets flowing and your
competitive juices are at their maximum
you're going to forget or you're just
not going to care a lot of these guys
okay you think sims would care i mean my
god he lets him fly all the time anyway
and he knows he shouldn't if he was in a
setting where uh oh well it's up to them
to bleep me he'll let it fly all the
time and i think there's a lot of guys
who think the same way especially once
they're out there and they're exerting
effort they're being hit and attacking
people so i don't know what the solution
is i hope they find a way to make it
work even if it is aggressive use of the
bleep button i want to hear the
unvarnished unfiltered audio from the
field from the sidelines and that would
be part of these broadcasts if there
isn't artificial crowd noise it's used
these are all things that people well
above my pay grade are looking into to
determine what is the right approach for
the nfl and for the various networks i
love coach madden's
advice though to fred gidelli the sunday
night football producer shy away from
the crowd noise embrace the ambient
noise that you pick up on the field and
that we're going to be able to hear much
more loudly than we ever do if there is
no fan noise in the stands all right
next up pftp and posse does being
critical of nfl general managers coaches
owners etc impact your relationship with
them or make it awkward when you're
interviewing them and if so how what
about barstool big cat who has yet to oh
they're trying to get him to join the
pft and posse he's not going to do that
let me just answer the question
being critical of general managers
coaches and owners does impact the
relationship that is the balance and
that is the challenge and
you know as you get to know these folks
and i remember the first time i ever did
anything by way of attending an nfl
related event i went to steelers
training camp in 2006 first time i ever
met peter king i went there uh and spent
the day
and you know met some people and uh
as i was walking out of the facility
somebody who i know called me and said
don't do it don't do it don't start
going to things don't start covering
games don't start going to practices
don't start interviewing people don't
get to know these guys because you will
lose your edge if you do
and i i've always taken the position
that there's a way
to have the relationships but also say
what needs to be said when it needs to
be said and
usually what that entails is having a
level of sensitivity where if it's
someone you know
and you are going to rip them
you you give them a heads up
and you say hey look i'm just i got to
do my job here i just want you to be
aware of what i'm going to be writing i
want you to be aware of what i'm going
to be saying and sometimes the benefit
there is you get
a different perspective you get their
perspective you get their side of it
which is even though i didn't go to
journalism school it's kind of the thing
you're supposed to do
so you factor in their viewpoint before
you finalize your own opinion and
actually that relationship can enhance
number one my understanding of a
situation maybe guide me in a bit of a
different direction once i have the
benefit of of that person's input and it
makes for a better take it makes for a
better opinion it makes for a more
informed overall
assessment of a situation so uh yeah it
definitely is an issue um when someone
gives you access
number one your now here's where it
becomes a challenge
i i try not
to be
even more of an ass
to the people who don't give us access i
never want to be vindictive about and if
it's a team that just says no we're not
going to do it and they never do it
i try not to let that influence my
opinions where it's like i'm always
going after this team because this team
doesn't make its coaches gm its owner
it's whoever available because i don't
think that's the right thing to do the
right thing to do is have your honest
opinion shaped by what you see what you
hear what is happening and you come up
with your criticism that way and i don't
think it's right to just dump on whoever
it is that isn't giving access um
although i guess that would be a more
effective way to get access because
sometimes you give up on someone enough
they give you access because they want
you to stop that's how i
and it wasn't intentional this was in
2005.
first big city and i said the first big
event i ever did was the 2006
um
training camp with steelers the 2005 i
had to sit down
with nick saban and that was a
direct result of the fact that so many
of the media members
in miami couldn't stand him
and they were feeding to me
all the stuff he was doing that pissed
them off so we were hammering him and
that resulted in the dolphins reaching
out and trying to set up a meeting and
an interview is kind of a way to to have
a truce i didn't set out to do it that
way but that's when i realized the power
of being an ass if you're an ass enough
you you do get access but i don't i
don't think that's right i just don't
think that's right i don't think it's
right to strategically say i'm gonna go
after this person to try to shame them
or
or up or basically squeeze them leverage
them into giving me an interview i just
don't think that's right you form your
opinions based upon what you see what
you hear and you go forward and if you
get access you get access if you don't
you know all right hope that is question
if not tough [ __ ] sorry we'll believe
that i guess uh let's see
pfd pm posse good memory in your first
pft sunday mailbag you mentioned an
exciting new twist on how we've done
things coming to pft live in the not too
distant future any updates on this
anything you can share no next question
uh let's go james mcdonough
dr j144 this is one of those that i
didn't read in advance what goes through
your mind when you post an article which
you know about half of the people are
going to be angry about because they see
it as politics can you really brush off
the criticism or is some of it hard to
ignore and frustrating that's a great
question
here's here's what happens
um
you know when these issues come up that
are potentially
political
but they are connected to the nfl
because
what we're seeing right now
multiple nfl figures
sounding off about what happened to
george floyd the murder of george floyd
and i let it go for a couple of days
because i didn't know what to do
but then
i wish i had a cough button down here
but then
when the vikings issued a statement
about it's like all right here we go the
nfl team issuing a statement about the
murder of george floyd they didn't call
it a murder i did because it was
um i'm gonna go with it then and i when
i write the story i know
it's gonna piss off certain people and i
know when i tweet it i'm gonna get the
stick to sports reaction and other
pejoratives that are thrown my way i
just don't care now look at some level
you do care when you feel like you're
being unfairly attacked by someone and
when you know that they're doing it
because they don't want to deal with the
message so they're going to attack the
messenger it really is that simple i
mean the stick to sports crowd only
activates in response to something that
they disagree with or something that
makes them uncomfortable they don't
react when you are saying something that
they like
so i try to keep that in mind that part
of it is just the human nature way of
dealing with somebody expressing an
opinion that makes the person who sees
that opinion uncomfortable and i think
that
a lot of what people are saying when it
comes to the murder of george floyd
right the people pushing back
i'm not going to say they're racist but
that they support police officers
murdering
african-americans and other minorities
but just the concept the topic all the
discussion makes them uncomfortable
because it invades on their law and
order top-down view of how things should
be and the police are always right no
matter what and life is easier if we
have these bright lines and we don't
question the authority of the police and
they have the discretion to do whatever
needs to be done and anything that makes
me uncomfortable in that mindset it
disrupts that viewpoint is going to piss
me off and get me to tell people to
stick to sports now look this is an
extreme example it makes it harder it
makes it harder
for the people who would be inclined to
ignore the message
to retreat to that stick to sports
mantra but i think what's happening here
is you know if you can find a deflection
like pointing to the riots pointing to
the looting
that that becomes the thing that you
pivot to so you don't have to feel
uncomfortable
about the fundamental problem which is
the murder of george floyd you've got
something else you can talk about so
instead of being uncomfortable about
something that needs to be changed you
would rather not see change because you
don't want the authority of the police
officers to be undermined on a specific
or general scale you pivot to these
other things whether it's decrying the
rioting decrying the looting or decrying
those who are
staying
not in their lane by talking about these
uncomfortable issues but i i ultimately
look
if you're not human if it doesn't bother
you
but at the same time
i i consciously accept the fact
that i need to do it because ultimately
if you think it's the right thing to do
and uh look i i think that
when you have developed a platform and
i've worked hard over the last 20 years
to develop this platform and
i'm not using that aspect of it to
promote an agenda that i think is unfair
and proper these are areas where
i believe that the right thing to do is
to say
they murdered george floyd and we need
to pay attention to the message that a
guy like colin kaepernick was sending
back in 2016. you may disagree with the
method but the message is what he was
trying to get people to talk about and
that is the fact that there are so many
police officers out there aren't
properly trained in how to and how to
deal with difficult situations uh you
know they pull out the gun and they fire
it when they shouldn't or they bury
their knee into the neck of somebody for
more than seven or eight minutes and
kill them whatever the case may be there
is reason to
to be concerned about whether or not
every police officer has the requisite
skill and training and experience to
properly interact with people without
killing that's a viable message so
i believe in that i think it's the right
thing to do i i don't know why anyone
would support police brutality against
anyone so
i'm gonna use this platform that i've
built when i believe it's the right
thing to do to send that message
especially when that message is being
sent
by the men and by the organizations
involved in the national footballing and
that's my prerogative if people don't
like it there's plenty of other places
where you can get sports news from
people who either
don't care
about sending a message of right and
wrong on the platforms they've built or
they've got different messages that
they're going to send through those
platforms and the same thing with the
pandemic and this is the thing that has
driven me crazier than anything i've
encountered in 20 years of doing this
and i know that the national will has
kind of moved the needle toward opening
up everything and trying to get back to
normal but you know early on when social
distancing was more prevalent when the
stay-at-home orders were as clear as
they could be the reactions from people
when when we'd point out you know
probably not the best idea for dak
prescott dez bryant to be out having a
workout touching the same football
clearly within six feet of each other in
the early days of the pandemic before
the the peaks of the of the infection
came and we were all being told what we
needed to do it was amazing to me how
many people got mad about them i mean
it's the right thing to do you know and
and i really i it's the i don't think
these are controversial positions it's
just a sense of what is right and what
is wrong and when it comes down to
people like george floyd and what
happened to him you know i'll say what
i've written at the website and what
i've written on twitter
you either care about the well-being and
the rights of others or you don't it's
that simple it's a binary choice you
care about others or you don't
and if you don't just own it right just
just just get on it don't try to act
like you're something that you're not if
you don't care about others own it don't
make those who do care about others feel
bad about it don't attack them
for disrupting your little
peace and quiet corner of the world
where you'd rather not have anyone
pointing out that there is a chance that
you're wrong that there is a chance that
you lack the soul you lack the heart you
like the caring for your fellow man to
be upset when police officers kill a man
who
look he was suspected of committing a
crime but my god
forgery uh passing a counterfeit bill
whatever it was
it was not hardly anything close to the
kind of thing that would allow the use
of any type of potentially lethal force
so you either care or you don't i care
and if you don't that's your problem and
if you don't want to come to visit pft
if you don't want to take in the pft pm
podcast if you don't want to watch pft
live you don't want to go to the twitter
page yes
that's your prerogative part of me would
would rather you only be part of this
community if you share in my belief that
we should care about the rights and the
well-being of our fellow men and women
regardless of what they look like
regardless of their backgrounds
regardless of who they are we are all in
this together we are all americans
and i don't think uh it's healthy for
anyone to start drawing lines and saying
that certain groups have
greater rights than others all right
let's move on to the next question
leapfrogs 500 what is the plan for teams
who have multiple players tests positive
how will testing work will it be daily
and will teams be sequestered i still
don't know what the plan is ultimately
going to be i know what i think it
should be what i think it should be is
very simple there should be an airlock
at every team facility and everyone who
shows up
is
should be required to take a test
to test negative before they can enter
the facility every person every day
needs to test negative now
i think there may be certain people that
don't need to test negative
um but i'm talking about football staff
coaches players trainers anybody who's
going to be in that petri dish that is
the locker room needs to test negative
before they enter
and i also think they need to test
negative before they exit i think part
of the nfl's responsibility to the
community is to make sure that no one is
coming out of a facility
after having tested positive or actually
become positive for the coronavirus
during the time they're at the facility
now look i don't know enough about the
science to know how long it takes to go
from exposure to testing positive
but but i just think as a basic
practical matter
more testing is going to be better than
less testing testing every day on the
way in and on the way out i think is the
only way to do it by the time we get to
august in september i think there'll be
more than enough tests to do it the
right way i don't know how long it's
going to take to turn around the results
but obviously you need a test where you
can either get a pin prick of your
finger or swab the inside of your mouth
and know within five ten fifteen minutes
whether or not you're positive for the
coronavirus and look i was told several
weeks ago that you know away from public
eye there's a lot of stuff happening to
create the advancements necessary to get
to the point where the testing will be
that simple and also the anagen stats
what does it mean to have the
coronavirus antibodies does it mean you
can't get sick from it does it mean you
can't infect someone else even if you're
exposed to the virus again we'll know
more about that by september there's
some tests and some research being done
in korea that i i think has been very
illuminating from the standpoint of
potentially getting the nfl to the point
where it can say hey if you're positive
for the antibodies you're good to go
fill the stadiums that would be great
news for the nfl if that's the truth
it'd be great news for society if that's
the truth because anyone who's positive
for the antibodies knows they don't have
to be worried about getting it and they
don't have to worry about giving it to
someone else because that's the other
sadness and that's one of the things
that bothers me about this
the the the people
and you know there's folks in the media
who
i'm not gonna name names you know who
they are and they know who they are
people who i think are deliberately
selling
a message
to people who want to hear you know this
is the flip side of what i was saying
earlier there are people out there who
get pissed off when someone says
something that makes them uncomfortable
because it makes them doubt their own
views and it makes them think that their
views may not be the right views on the
other side of the coin you're going to
have people who are deliberately saying
things whether they believe them or not
and i believe that some of these folks
who are saying these things don't really
believe it but they're trying to pander
to
the folks who want
to hear that
it's the flip side of of cramming your
fingers in your ears and saying i'm not
listening this is the oh i really want
to listen to this well thank you very
much you're making me feel better about
the decisions i'm making the positions
i'm taking because you get me you
understand me you're saying what i want
to hear because i think the message
that's being said to a lot of those
people and i think it ends up becoming
you know as kind of a self-fulfilling
prophecy this idea that
that you know i'm allowed to take risks
i'm an american i can take risks i have
the freedom to take risks and i'm hey
i'm going to go live my life i'm not
going to go hide under the bed if i get
coronavirus i'll deal with it that's
fine
if it wasn't something that you could
infect someone else with that's the
thing that amazes me about this you can
infect someone else it may not affect
you it may not make you sick but you can
give it to someone else and they could
die from it it's that simple they could
die from well the only people have to
worry about are people who are older and
who have pre-existing conditions folks
do you realize how many people are out
there who have diabetes and they don't
know they have diabetes not everybody
who is diabetic knows they're diabetic
there's always a period of time and for
some people it can be months if not
years before they go to a doctor and
they recognize that the reason they
don't feel good every day is because
they got type 2 diabetes
and it's a hell of a way to find out
that you're diabetic if you get covered
19 and die from it so you know this
isn't as clear
and it's not as simple and it's not
basically a matter of saying
i'm willing to take the risk of getting
the coronavirus
you're taking the risk that you're going
to give it to someone else you're going
to give it to someone that you think
it won't kill
and look i i i don't need to see the
numbers
to know that
you know
we've seen the names we've seen the
faces we've seen the ages and i would
suspect that the younger folks who have
died from this not every single one of
them
had a serious health condition and knew
they had a serious health condition so
that's why there needs to be a little
more concern here and i think that's
part of the responsibility the nfl has
it's part of the responsibility the
media has and hopefully
we'll get to the point where there is a
way to conduct the season in a manner
that is safe to the players
it is safe to the public and it allows
the games to be played and that's
ultimately what i want i mean that's the
other thing too
just because
we take the time to articulate the
potential things that could affect the
season because of the pandemic it
doesn't mean we're rooting against the
season people
it's possible to be concerned about the
things that could screw up the season
and to articulate that because you hope
that somebody is planning for it so it
doesn't screw up the season we're not
rooting for there to be no season we're
rooting for the people in a position of
power and influence to anticipate the
things that could come up and to
identify those things and have a plan
for those things so it doesn't screw
everything up so it doesn't require the
nfl to either not start the season at
all or pull the plug in october or
november if there is a second wave that
overwhelms the country so i mean again
again
fundamental guiding principle
either care about your fellow man
or you don't
and if you don't
you know what you just need to admit it
to yourself it's okay you have the right
to be an uncaring prick it's your right
i'm not saying you shouldn't be
but but go be an uncaring prick and
leave the rest of us alone don't
infringe on our ability to care about
other people don't make us feel bad
because we care don't attack us for
having an agenda of fairness and justice
and equity
and
basic level of care for our fellow man
just go go live in a hole somewhere go
go create your own little society
somewhere with all the other pricks and
leave the rest of us alone it's that
simple sorry sorry to the pricks out
there who don't care about other people
actually i'm not sorry what else do we
have here
[Music]
cory joskowitz barring any clippers type
scandals what do you think would be the
next team to have ownership available
for sale owners don't want to sell
because teams only appreciate
but there have to be people like david
tepper chomping at the bit to get their
hands on a team here's the thing to
watch and i'm not going to name names
but here's what you need to watch you
need to watch for teams that are
primarily owned by someone who is older
what happens
when that person dies
will the estate will the holdings of
that family be sufficient
to pay the estate taxes
to allow someone else to inherit the
equity that was held by the person who
dies
or will it force the sale of the team
and again i'm not going to name names i
i don't want to go down that path
but
there are multiple franchises out there
where there's a question of whether or
not there would be enough cash
is there enough cash to write the
gigantic check to the government for the
estate tax
and still be able to own the team do you
have to sell some of the team to pull it
off do you have to sell all the team to
pull it off that's how jack kent cook's
family ended up selling the washington
franchise it's house joe robbie's family
ended up selling the dolphins franchise
it's happened multiple times in the past
i'm sure there's other examples i can
think of but but that's really the key
when there is the passing of
typically a patriarch of the family but
sometimes a matriarch in the family like
like what we saw with the rams the rams
got sold after georgia frontieri passed
um now part of it may be the family just
doesn't want to take over the team
that's what happened with ralph wilson
when he passed the the fam nobody in the
family wanted to run the team so they
sold the team period they may very well
have been able to pay the estate taxes
and continue to own the team if they
wanted to but but that's what we need to
watch will teams that are held by a
family will those teams be able to
continue to be held by that family once
the one person who owns the biggest
chunk of the team passes away that's
when the window of opportunity is going
to open and uh you know what happened
with david tepper and the panthers there
was a scandal involving jerry richardson
that forced him to sell the team but if
he hadn't done that
when jerry richardson passed away and he
still hasn't yet but when he would have
that would have been the moment where
the team likely would have been
available for sale but look here's the
thing not many of these teams come
available for sale and they do
appreciate to the point where it becomes
harder and harder to find anyone who has
the money
to buy the minimum equity and then has
the money to actually operate the team
all right now let's see what else we
have here
i don't know 40 how long do you think it
takes for marcus mariota to replace
derek carr i i don't know that it's
definitely going to happen just because
it happened to mariota last year in
tennessee with ryan tannehill i don't
think it's a done deal and i get accused
all the time of being too hard on derek
carr i just think it's kind of funny
that that he's as sensitive as he is
because you always think that the nfl
quarterback is going to be a little you
know a little more thicker skin it's one
thing for me to be thin skin i'm not an
nfl quarterback i'm not out there in
that in that pit of of physicality with
guys you know constantly buzzing around
me and trying to hit me and trying to
hurt me not trying to hurt maybe you get
the point they're trying to hit me and
it may hurt me if they hit uh
intercepting passes making calm
decisions weird to see somebody who's
thin skin in that setting um i uh i i
don't know i don't know i i kind of
think that maybe derek carr is gonna be
good enough this year to hold off marcus
mariota and i just wonder whether marcus
mariota is good enough to take over the
job ryan tannehill was a guy who i think
was better than he got credit for i
don't know that marcus mariota falls in
that category so i don't think it's
inevitable that mario is going to take
over for derek carr now if car gets hurt
that's going to be an opportunity for
mario to maybe take the job but we'll
see if that happens all right let's see
what else we have here probably should
wrap this up total
uh
program today i think we're well over an
hour which makes it one of the longer
pft pms we've had in a while
um let me just look for one more here
one more
uh
last one cz wall this gets back to the
uh the george floyd situation thank you
for the great article on george floyd
in my home city non-football related and
i'm behind on tft but what are your
general thoughts on the subsequent days
of variety how do we better ensure
peaceful protest look i don't think
rioting is an appropriate way to handle
a situation where an injustice was
committed but the reality is
when you have people
who believe that injustice is done
and when steps aren't immediately taken
to address the injustice
you run the risk
that people are going to
demonstrate
and that demonstration may cross the
line
when you allow that group dynamic to
take over so
i think the more swiftly the justice is
done
the more quickly that we we avoid the
possibility of riots and looting and
other things that shouldn't happen
it's not an acceptable outcome but
it shouldn't be a surprise when it
happens when there is a fundamental
injustice that is routinely visited upon
certain elements of society and it never
gets any better i mean we have a problem
we have a flaw in our system that
continues to rear its ugly head in the
death of people who should not be dying
at the hands of police officers if we
don't fix that
if we don't fundamentally address the
problem and fix it there will be
a stronger and stronger sense of
injustice you've got a problem that is
hiding in plain sight that no one seems
to be doing anything about fixing with
each passing example of that problem
taking a life that you shouldn't have
taken you do run the risk
that the volume is going to be a little
bit louder and a little bit louder and a
little bit louder and eventually it's
going to explode and that's what's
happening in minneapolis and it's
unfortunate the rioting should not
happen the looting should not happen the
police precinct should not be set on
fire this should not be going on
but ultimately if we achieve a spot
where police officers are properly
trained
properly held accountable for their
behavior and ultimately properly
interact with other people
of all races of all creeds of all colors
of all backgrounds
when all people receive the same
treatment and fair treatment and proper
treatment from law enforcement to people
who walk around among us with lethal
force and the ability to use it
and at times it feels like whenever they
want to without repercussion until we
get to a point where there is
repercussion from the system
that's when unfortunately until we get
there there will continue to be these
kinds of incidents so look how do we
stop the rioting we stop the events
that light the fuse
on the ride
and
uh yeah when you have a press conference
yesterday from a local prosecutor who
says well i don't see anything here that
justifies prosecution that's one of the
ingredients in people who recognize a
fundamental unfairness reacting and it's
wrong to react the way they did
but that's what happens when you have
case after case after case incident
after incident after incident the
frustration grows and eventually it
explodes so the greater obligation for
our politicians for our leaders for our
people
demand more expect more and eventually
maybe we get more from people in law
enforcement who from time to time are
committing heinous crimes against
american citizens that is what needs to
end and the sooner that ends the sooner
the rioting will stop and the sooner the
other problems associated with what
happened to people like george floyd
will come to a conclusion the pft pm
podcast comes to a conclusion we
appreciate your participation we'll be
back on monday on pft live we'll try to
do some more pft pm podcasts we continue
to try to line up coaches and general
managers because what the hell else are
they doing right
and they i think they like the zoom
interaction
i think that a lot of these folks prefer
to pop open a laptop and have a
conversation where they can see me and i
can see them as opposed to doing it over
the telephone there's there's a greater
personalization of the conversation so i
enjoy doing them and hopefully we'll
have more of them coming up in the month
of june we hope you all have a safe
weekend and uh
we again appreciate your your ongoing
support of pro footballtalk.com and all
of our various products we'll talk to
you again next week
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports